the number one question i ask people
whenever somebody tells you they're rich
the number one question is the question
i ask you the number one question i
asked you was well when we started i
said how do you make your money what do
you do and you said
tv i worked on some big films i ended up
doing
advertising in 2000 and i think you said
11. yeah
and you know i got into advertising i
did some big companies i did some local
companies great so in my mind
you're an advertiser and you're a good
interviewer you're curious you asked the
right question
you got a channel that's soon to be over
a million subs on your way to 10 million
subscribers right okay great
but i i went to how did you make your
money the number one question
a lot of these online uh gurus that you
call when you ask them how do you make
your money
they don't have an answer to that
question the way they made their money
is selling courses selling courses so by
the way
and and if they open up and say that
then that's okay
meaning if you say how did you make your
money i made my money selling courses
okay cool
you know it's versus how did you make
your money well i made my money because
i did a real estate deal and i sold this
real estate deal for 28 million dollars
how do we know you sold it for 28
million how do we not know your share is
only 50 000
but the story is 28 million dollars for
example i bought a hotel here for 36
million
okay do you know how much of an owner i
was on that 36 million
hotel we bought you didn't buy it with
grant cardone did you no
no no no i bought it so i bought a hotel
here for 36 million dollars
but do you know how much of that hotel i
owned how much
less than a percent so so when people
said how much does it buddy i don't own
the hotel i just am one of the
investors in this hotel a very small
percentage they said hey you want to put
some money into it
you know here's 50 grand here's 100
grand but
you can spin it and say i have a
you know so so a lot of that is on the
marketing side and look
and nobody nowadays walks on water so if
anybody wants to go out there and say
oh i'm holy i don't do anything wrong
sometimes you got to be careful because
if you play the card if i'm holy and i'm
an angel and you know i don't do
anything wrong
that can also backfire on you this is
why for me being married i tell you what
my wife and i say to each other i'll say
it all the time
when we got married people ask me a
question they said oh my gosh
you know at my wedding there were people
on one side uh it was all the
hairy middle eastern folks you know who
look like me they're all the same they
look the same
and then on the other side is all the
good-looking blue-eyed green-eyed people
like yourself my wife's family right
they're all
uh uh you know so they're standing on
one side they're all standing on one
side and they look at each other no
one's dancing it's a big wedding we got
450 people there at this wedding
then one of my friends gets up he is
hammered
he's so hammered it's not even fun he's
so hammered his wife's next to him he's
flirting with other people's wives he's
that hammered right there
he's that gone okay and he's the kind of
guy you want to party with because
in a different career he could have been
vince vaughn from uh wedding crashers
okay he's like that kind of a
personality he's trying to give you a
visual
good-looking guy he gets up he says look
i'm not gonna lie
uh you guys seem very concerned about
this you know wedding
whether this is gonna work out or not i
i am in the same place i don't have a
clue whether this is gonna work he's one
of my groomsmen
he says but i finally figured out what
jennifer and patrick have in common
jennifer's from texas patrick's from
iran
he says look both of these guys like
weapons of mass destruction and they're
like oil i think this is gonna work out
right everybody starts laughing
cracking up and they started dancing i'm
giving my final speech and i said well
listen a lot of you guys are wondering
whether this thing is going to work out
or not you know there's some vegas odds
right now whether it is or not all i can
tell you is this
i know one thing for fact i know for a
fact we can be married for one year
we're gonna take it one year at a time
so we went one year two years now we've
been married for 11 years
i'm not going to put the pressure we're
going to be together forever why would
you do that you don't know what happens
tomorrow so
you know sometimes these online folks
that play the
holy card it's one of the reasons why i
was an atheist for 25 years because i
grew up in a church that people get up
and talk about god and how perfect they
are
and next thing you know you know they're
the ones that are judging you that end
up doing the things that they
judged you on and you're sitting there
saying listen man this is exactly why i
don't want to go to church
but then you eventually find a community
where they say i'm here because i'm also
screwed up i don't want to go to church
and you remind me that i'm going to hell
i know i'm going to hell i just want to
know i got a spot in heaven you know
that kind of like that mindset
of going to a place so i do believe
there's a great place for guys like this
that are doing what they're doing
because there are a lot of people online
that they simply made their money
selling their courses
online and they should just come out and
say here's how i made my money i made my
money selling courses
right but the thing is about it if they
said that they probably wouldn't sell
nearly as many courses and those people
are
right they want to make money that's why
they're in that's why they're doing what
they're doing and they need to sell
those clicks
and there's also a lot of people i just
did an interview with a guy recently
who his name is have you ever heard of
him his name's coffeezilla
i have not so basically he uh he
he exposes quote-unquote fake gurus
he exposes people who go online and and
uh
basically try to create or falsify a
persona of them having
extreme wealth like having ferraris in
the background
of their shots or whatever and then uh
essentially all they're trying to do is
to sell like courses online courses
where they can you know
get vulnerable people with little to no
money
who have hit rock bottom who they need
need to find
they're looking for some sort of light
to bring them out of the darkness
and they find these guys with these
flashy cars these big watches find out
how i make five thousand dollars a day
on amazon
and uh it's super interesting and
there's a there's a huge
culture of people like that on youtube i
mean
he's got a couple hundred thousand
subscribers if it's working for him
look in in the world some people want to
be lawyers
right yeah what's a lawyer a lawyer sits
there and
tries to fight for their defend their
client but at the same time expose you
if they're going up against you that's
their job so to you
this person's lawyer is annoying because
they're exposing you right but it
is there is a need for lawyers as much
as we hate lawyers there's a need for
lawyers right okay
cops you can't stand a cop when he's
pulling you over
and it's annoying you know especially if
the cop is a little bit of a
arrogant prick and he thinks he's got
the badge he can kind of push you around
but look if if you're going out the
other day i got pulled over by this cop
he pulls me over i said what did i what
did you pull me over so he says what did
i pull you over for i said what'd you
pull me over for
he says first of all you made a u-turn
you didn't uh put the with the turn
signal
you s you were drifting the car then you
went and passed the red light
and you were speeding and you were about
to race the guy next to you
and you're lucky i don't have a gun on
me i can give you six tickets right
i said you know what you're right i do
deserve all this stuff right so
he comes back he says look just the fact
that you were chill i'm giving you one
ticket i said cool
thank you we had a great 15-minute
conversation i left right
there is a place for guys like that
there is a place for guys like that you
know when i was in l.a there was a uh
for the cop no for this guy with coffee
zillow what you're talking about
right yeah absolutely there is a place
for for
for people like that would they go and
say hey look i'm gonna expose now
he may be right or wrong but he's going
to expose and let the audience make a
decision for themselves
on what they want to do because you are
right there are a lot of people online
right now where
anybody can go out there and say i'm
worth half a billion dollars
people are going to believe it this is
why you know it's so interesting you
bring him up
you